I don't want to not accept
responsibility for what I did because I
think that's wrong especially at this
stage of my life let's put it this way
had my father never introduced me to
that life
I would have never gone down to criminal
path that's not who I was but on the
other hand I had it in me to do what I
had to do so I wonder myself sometimes
you know what is the real you in other
words if you were presented with a
situation when you had to do something
you did it is that the real you even
though you were uncomfortable I've asked
myself this question quite a bit but
being I was capable of doing it back
then was it the real me is it the real
me you might think that because you as I
said because you had decided to abide by
this moral code and that it was a moral
code that you wouldn't be conscience
ridden for doing some of the things you
had to do to stay part of the family
because you'd already defined yourself
in that way and also Define that as
ethical but it was still grating against
something in you and I would say
hopefully that whatever was calling you
to conscience was more the real you than
the you that was stepping outside of
your conscience to do the terrible
things that you did it's very
interesting to me that despite your oath
and your discipline following of the
appropriate practices that you were
still guilty
[Music]
hello everyone watching on YouTube or
listening on my podcast I have the
opportunity today to speak to Michael
Francis who has an extraordinarily
interesting life
um one that might be characterized but
as breaking Good Michael Francis grew up
as the son of the notorious underboss of
New York's violent and feared Columbo
crime family
Francis was quote one of the biggest
money earners the mob had seen since El
Capone end quote and the youngest
individuals on Fortune Magazine's list
of the 50 biggest Mafia bosses ranking
number 18 just five behind John Gotti
at his most affluent
Francis generated an estimated five to
eight million dollars per week from
legal and illegal businesses
it was a life filled with power luxury
and deadly violence
Michael's story is a modern day Damascus
Road experience
from his early days in the mob and rise
to power to God's leading him to do the
unthinkable quit the mob and follow
Christ
in fact nobody a franzisi's rank had
ever just walked away and lived
Michael's compelling story of
transformation is featured in his
autobiography blood Covenant he's also
written several other books including
this thing of ours and The Good The Bad
and The forgiven he's appeared widely in
both Christian and secular high-profile
media including the 700 Club Life
Magazine Vanity Fair Sports Illustrated
GQ and many others
thank you very much Mr franzis for
agreeing to talk to me today well thanks
for having me Jordan yeah well this
should be a very interesting
conversation
um so let's go back to the beginning I
guess
um you had a quite a let's say checkered
past decades ago you were involved in
organized crime at the highest level of
organization really and I I suppose in
in your way very successful
um at it and so let's start with that
what
maybe we could go back even to your
teenage years I mean tell me about your
family and and how this all came about
well I was born in Brooklyn New York and
my dad Sonny Francis was the underboss
of the Colombo family one of the five
New York mafia cousin ostra families
and my dad was a very very high profile
figure at the time during the 50s and
60s and right into the 70s he was very
well known and he was a major Target of
law enforcement a major Target of the
media back then I always say he was kind
of like the John Gotti of his day I'm
sure most people know of John
and so I grew up in an atmosphere Jordan
where
um I love my dad very much he was a good
father he originally didn't want this
life for me he wanted me to go to school
and be a doctor he wanted me to stay off
the street but we were surrounded by law
enforcement all the time and I always
viewed them as the enemy because they
were trying to harass my family harass
my father
and I grew up with people always talking
negative about law enforcement so on and
so forth and I experienced that from the
time I was four or five years old up
until you know my teenage years and then
after that
and it took a real turn of events during
the 60s my dad was indicted several
times he was indicted three times in the
state of New York for some very serious
crimes grand larceny and murder
he went to trial on all three of those
charges and was acquitted he was found
not guilty but then in 1966 he was
indicted in federal court for
masterminding a nationwide string of
bank robberies after lengthy trial he
gets convicted in 1967 they sentenced
him to 50 years in prison it was I
believe the longest sentence for a bank
robbery conspiracy case ever given up to
that point
1970 he loses all his appeals and they
ship him off to Leavenworth penitentiary
to do his time and I was a pre-med
student at that point at Hofstra
University in New York
but when my dad went away which was
essentially a death sentence he was 50
years old when he went in we figured he
had 50 on top of that he'd never come
out of prison alive
and then Joe Colombo who was the boss of
the Colombo family somebody we knew very
well he kind of took me under his wing
I would meet a lot of my dad's friends
at the time Joe Colombo had started the
Italian-American civil rights League
which was supposed to you know Safeguard
Italian Americans from being harassed by
the FBI
and I got very active in a league I saw
it as a way to help my dad and during
that time I was actually picketing the
FBI building in Manhattan and being a
very active participant in what Joey was
trying to do Columbo was trying to do
and um I lost interest in school because
a lot of my father's friends were
telling me if you don't go to school and
help your father out he's going to die
in prison
you know I believe my father was
innocent because I asked him I said Dad
bank robbery it doesn't make sense and
you know he looked at me we're in the
visiting room of Leavenworth and he said
that son I'm not a bank robbery he said
I was framed on these charges and he
said we got to work to get these charges
overturned or I'm going to spend the
rest of my life in prison and it was a
turning point for me during that visit
uh when I said look I'm not going to
school anymore if I don't help you out
you're going to die in here and
basically at that point he proposed me
for membership in the Colombo family I
was 20 years 21 years old when that
happened and that's when my life started
to take a shift
[Music]
government continues to spend borrowed
money inflation continues to swell
dragging down our economy and the stock
market has entered bear territory so
what's your plan are your assets
Diversified I'm Phillip Patrick precious
metal specialist for the Birch gold
group for nearly 20 years we've helped
Americans diversify into gold and we can
help you too did you know you can own
physical gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account we can help you
transfer an IRA or 401K tied to stocks
into an IRA in Gold if you're skeptical
about the trajectory of the economy in
the US dollar then text Jordan to 989898
Birch gold group will send you a free
info kit on securing your savings with
gold with thousands of satisfied
customers five star reviews and an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau we take Precious Metals seriously
text Jordan to 989898 for your free info
kit
so what did what did being inducted into
the Colombo family mean
well you know you can't just go up to
somebody in that life and say hey I'd
like to join you know somebody has to
propose you vouch for you say you have
what it takes to be a member
and uh for me it was my dad he proposed
me to membership and you know there is a
a process to becoming a made man or a an
official member of that life
and you go through a process where you
have to prove yourself worthy of
becoming a member
and you know it could have been you know
there were guys at the time Jordan they
had an expression in the life where the
books were closed from the 1950s up
until that point in the mid 70s they
weren't officially bringing any more
members into that life because it was
security reasons and this was all five
families in New York uh uh kept to that
but then they opened the books again in
the 70s so there were guys actually
waiting 20 years to become members of
that life just you know they were just
there 20 years for me it was a two and a
half year three year process because
like I said they had opened the books so
you know you have to prove yourself
worthy
um there's a lot of discipline in that
life a lot of authority
um a lot of alleged respect you know you
had a meeting at eight o'clock if you
weren't there at 7 30 you were late you
know it could never be late in that life
and you just had to follow the orders
whatever you were told to do you know
it's it's difficult for me to share say
this but you know I like to be honest
about it you know that life at times is
violent and if you're part of that life
you're part of the violence
and um it took me two and a half years
before I proved myself worthy and it was
actually Halloween night in 1975 when I
took an oath and became a sworn made
member of the Colombo family
and what sort of things did you have to
do what sort of things were you called
upon to do in order to be deemed worthy
of membership well again you know when I
first
um one after my dad proposed me it was
about two weeks later when an official
in the family a captain picked me up
and he took me to see the boss now I
don't know if you're aware but uh Joe
Colombo had been shot seriously wounded
at a big rally that we had in Columbus
Circle uh back in
1971. he eventually died from the wounds
and I was about 12 steps away from him
when that happened on the stage was kind
of the first eye-opening experience that
I had in that life
and um
you know you uh I was told straight out
you know they said to me do you want to
become a member of this life and I said
yes and they said well here's the deal
it was a new boss that had tooken over
his name was Tom debella Tom is passed
on now
and he said to me here's the deal from
now on 24 hours a day seven days a week
you're all called to serve this family
the Colombo family that means if your
mother is sick and she's dying and
you're at her bedside and we call you to
service you leave your mother's side you
come and serve us from now on we're
number one in your life before anything
and everything and when if we feel you
deserve this privilege this honor to
become a member we'll let you know so
from that moment on you have to do
whatever you're told to do to prove
yourself worthy and you know there was a
lot of menial things you know there was
times I had to drive the boss to a
meeting I sat in a car two three four
hours waiting for him to come out you
know God forbid you leave you go to the
restroom go get a newspaper he comes out
you're not there you're in trouble you
know stuff like that I know I did that
once and and paid the price I had a real
tongue lashing
um you know just a lot of things are
like that I mean a lot of times you're
just really hanging out and observing
and watching and listening
and uh you know I learned to be a very
good listener at that point Jordan I
just listened and observed and seen what
it was I need to do and what was it
expected of me and look you know again
to be honest there are times when you're
called upon within that life to commit
an act of violence and if you're told to
do it you need to do it and before
before you had gone into medical school
and and and then decided to take this
turn into your life had you been
involved in anything that was violent as
a child or a teenager
I never was involved myself I mean I had
fights you know I mean I had a a fight
two or three neighborhood fights I mean
my ribs were broken once I got hit with
a bat
um you know things like that scuffles
like that but nothing major but I
witnessed things you know my dad was
a fairly violent guy I mean I saw him
hit people
um so I witnessed that
um I didn't really enjoy seeing it but I
witnessed it at one time at a really
young age I think it was 10 or 11 years
old and he had you know trouble with
somebody on the street I was driving
with him and he was pretty violent with
the guy
how did you react to that when you were
11. it kind of scared me you know I
didn't see him like that
um with another guy so I was a little
concerned I said hey you know in my mind
I guess I was thinking this is this
going to get out of hand what's going to
happen and Two Fellas that were with my
dad walked over to me and said I was in
the car and they said Mike don't worry
about it probably shouldn't be seeing
this but everything is okay but it made
an impression on me
so all right so you you how far do you
got medical school uh when I was a
pre-med student uh it was my second year
I was a sophomore
basically a biology major what and what
happened with your father what happened
with your attempts to to to have his
case uh adjudicated re-adjudicated well
my dad actually did 40 years on that 50.
and he was paroled he made parole
because he was under the Old Law where
they still had parole uh in the federal
system back then today they don't have
it you got to do 85 percent of your time
but he was under the Old Law
and he after 10 years I actually did get
him out on parole but he kept going back
in and always always for associating
with other felons somebody alleged to be
an organized crime so he was paroled
five times violated five times and went
back in
and uh he ended up doing 40 on the 50 he
was actually released in 2017 for the
last time he was a hundred years old the
data was released he was actually the
oldest you know member of that life in
America probably in the world and he uh
he died at the age of 103 just uh two
two years ago hmm
so what did it mean to be in that time
at that time what did it mean to be part
of the kazanostra of five families in in
New York and and why five and how were
they were they bonded together or were
they competing with one another well
they didn't compete with one another but
uh there were rivalries at the time but
never rivalries that ended up in
violence because in that life there's a
perception that families used to fight
one another
that's that kind of uh activity stopped
in the 40s you know when Lucky Luciano
got together and and created the
commission and there was kind of a
ruling body over the five families the
boss of each family was involved in it
uh they didn't fight among one another
they settled disputes amicably Whenever
there was a war in that family was
always a civil war it was usually for
power or leadership so
um but I always say this Jordan I
believe the golden years if you want to
call them that of Mafia in New York and
maybe probably throughout the United
States was really from the 50s until the
mid 80s in the mid 80s things started to
fall apart when Rudy Giuliani started to
really use the racketeering laws and uh
put a lot of guys in prison created a
lot of informants and that's when the
life kind of made a uh a drastic turn
you know I guess for the better for
society but for the worse for them
but it was a big deal you know back then
I mean we had a lot of power and a lot
of control in this country
the midterms are upon us and it's time
for some real change inflation isn't
going away and if the current
Administration keeps handing out free
checks Americans won't just be hurting
they'll be fighting to survive the
typical Investment Portfolio of 60 40
stocks and bonds is down by 34 it's
worst drop of the century millions of
Americans are taking a hit what can we
do to set things right you could invest
in assets that aren't dragged down by
the stock market like fine art with
Masterworks Fine Art Is So disconnected
from stocks that even as the 60 40
portfolio keeps losing Fine Art is
selling for 26 percent more than it was
last year just recently Mass work sold a
painting for a 21.5 net return to their
investors go to masterworks.com and use
promo code jbp to sign up for
Masterworks and skip their waitlist
that's masterworks.com promo code jbp or
click the link in the description see
important disclosures at masterworks.com
CD
[Music]
yeah well it said in your bio that you
at the height of your activity you were
involved in criminal activity that was
generating something between five and
eight million dollars a week and that
would be in in the 70s if I've got the
timeline correct yes so that's an awful
lot of money what sort of so what sort
of activities were you overseeing and
what did that overseeing consist of
well you know there's um you kind of you
kind of find your own level in that life
and I like to explain it this way there
was kind of two types of people in that
life you were either a racketeer or a
gangster
a racketeer was a guy that knew how to
use that life to benefit him in business
and went out and made money not only for
himself but for the family
and a gangster was someone that was just
not capable of that and they were kind
of a I guess you can call it a thug you
know they were the guys who did a lot of
the street work
um if you're a racketeer you also had to
be a gangster at certain times because
you were you were you had to do that you
know that was something you had to do
but normally they tried to keep the guys
that were earning money you know earning
money because no organization survives
without money so I was fortunate I knew
how to use that life to benefit me in
business and I went on to make a very
significant amount of money what did we
do just about everybody in that life
um you know in that level isn't a
gambling like I had a lot of bookmakers
that were under my control because
bookmakers weren't really allowed to
operate on the street unless they were
some way affiliated with organized crime
we wouldn't let them
um you know I put out money on the
street at usurious rates people couldn't
go to a bank so they would come to me uh
we did that and I was um
again I was I was very aggressive on the
street I worked very hard and a lot of
people would come to me with different
schemes you know there's a there's a uh
a misconception that guys in that life
sit in their social clubs and look at
the next business that they're going to
attack or infiltrate or corrupt in some
way and that happens on occasion but
normally it's someone from the business
that would come to us and say hey we
have a scheme to defraud our company or
you know our business can you help us
and that happened to me quite often and
the biggest thing you know to answer
your question that I got involved in was
um I was involved in a scheme to defraud
the government out of tax on every
gallon of gasoline
and somebody brought the germ of an idea
for me and we uh we created that into a
huge huge uh Enterprise I would say
where we were generating eight to ten
million dollars a week
how was that implemented that that that
scam on on the gasoline tax front well
initially uh in New York and I think
throughout the country the tax Century
gallon was collected at the gas station
the gas station operator was obligated
to pay the tax
while that was happening we had 350 or
so gas stations that we'd owned or
operated and we installed people in all
of them and to make a long story short
you know it would take the government
about 10 months before they would come
down on a company that wasn't paying tax
and we had a way to
manipulate them so that it took 10
months
and then they changed the law and they
said that you had to be a licensed
wholesaler in order to collect the tax
and then you had to pay the government
well I had 18 companies that were
licensed to collect tax on every gallon
of gasoline and the same deal it took
them about 10 or 11 months before they
came down on us and we had accountants
working for us that were able to keep
them at Bay for that length of time and
then by the time they would come down on
a company we just closed the doors that
company would be over and we'd move to
the next license so we we did that for I
ran this operation for almost eight
years so how come the government didn't
clue in if they were losing the amount
of money that that you were siphoning
off that you said you ran this
repeatedly so if I've got it right you
set up a company you had about 11 month
window before the government would come
in and enforce its its tax collection so
you could collect money for 10 months
and then just kill the company and then
start another one correct and so and and
then you managed to do that for eight
years yes
so why didn't the government clue in
well they couldn't you know they were
investigating us they were trying to
clue in they just couldn't figure out
how we were doing it or what we were
doing and you know it was a pretty
sophisticated operation and we just
tried to stay one step ahead of them
which we were able to do
and it lasted that long I mean I had an
incident once where two FBI agents I had
also a couple of uh car agencies I had a
Mazda agency and a Chevrolet agency and
they visited me in my offices once and
they brought me outside and they said
look we have an idea what you're doing
we know what you're doing but we can't
figure it out just tell us help us and
we'll give you a pass on all this now
obviously I knew they weren't going to
give me a pass and I didn't cooperate
with them at the time but they knew
something was going down they just
couldn't figure it out we just stayed
ahead of them
and so how did it finally fold up after
eight years well my partner who
developed the scheme along with me he
was actually the one that brought me the
idea he had a small operation out in
Long Island and he got in trouble on an
unrelated case a tax issue a personal
tax issue that he had and at the time we
had a uh he was on trial
and we had a compound in um
Panama and the reason we had it there is
because there was no extradition between
Panama and the United States at that
point in time and so he was flying back
and forth to Panama and it was at some
point in time when he thought he was
going to be convicted on his case and he
didn't want to take the conviction so he
fled to Panama
and
um the FBI somehow uh they went and
kidnapped him in the middle of the night
so they bypassed the extradition loss
and they brought him into Florida and at
that point in time he agreed to be a
cooperating witness against me and I was
the target at that time I had several
investigations going on me at one time
and once he became an informant and
started cooperating he told them how the
whole scheme was coming down and that's
when it fell apart
so I'm curious about your personality
then and now I suppose it seems to me
that
juggling all these Enterprises Each of
which has a high probability of of
collapse and a high probability of
Investigation
um I would think of that as something
extraordinarily stressful and so how is
it that you were able to keep your head
well you were engaged in these
Enterprises and
because I can imagine if I was doing
that
I would be
apprehensive all the time as a
consequence of being pursued let's say
but obviously you were able to deal with
that and so how are you able to stay
composed well engaged in these
activities and why at that time did you
think it was worth it
well you know that's uh that's a good
question I I'll tell you you know it
wasn't only I was a target of law
enforcement from day one because my
dad's name was so high profile I mean I
had throughout my time in that life I
had 18 arrests they were on me all the
time I found out I also had seven
indictments I had five State indictments
and I had two Federal racketeering
indictments one that was brought on by
Rudy Giuliani and I went to trial five
times I was either dismissed or
acquitted in every case
and
um so I constantly was under
investigation
and on the other hand you know when
you're in that life you're constantly
watching out for the guy next to you
because that's the uh that's just the
way the life goes so
you know I mean I never analyze myself
and say how I how was I able to do this
I think part of it stemmed from
you know the resentment that I had from
law enforcement that hey you destroyed
my family you took my father away and
I'm just going to continue on this path
um but I will say this Jordan you know
people have asked me that uh many many
times there were things that I had to do
in that life that I was very
uncomfortable in doing I didn't like it
it wasn't part of who I was I believe
but you know in some way I mean I just
stepped outside of myself because I knew
I had to do it
um or so for consequences myself and I
did it and then I sprang back to who I
was before that I mean I don't know how
else to you know to say it
well you you said already that you had
constructed a pretty complex identity
you had a two and a half year
apprenticeship and as you get deeper in
and deeper into something that's more
and more of Who You Are
and so the alternative to continuing in
that vein is to do something radical
completely radical and different and
that's no easy thing to manage and I
think people do in their lives step
outside themselves quite frequently to
maintain what they have
so you you said part of it was that you
had been embattled on the law
enforcement front for a very very long
time and so you were pretty accustomed
to that and that you felt that the law
enforcement agencies were enemies and so
was that part of the Justified that was
part of the justification for engaging
in that in that in in those activities
yes I mean I saw law enforcement as
they're corrupt these are not good
people they framed my father they put
him in jail for a crime he didn't commit
uh it was very destructive to my family
I mean we had a you know I don't know
what any
family of any member of that life
including my own now not my wife and
kids thank God for that but mother
father brothers and sisters uh that
hasn't been totally devastated
and I guess I blame them in a big way
early on I wasn't blaming my father I
was blaming them and so anytime I was
able to get over them or fight with them
or argue with them I don't mean argue
verbal argue it but you know just
I just did it I went for it it was it
was very resentful on my part I had a
real resentment I see okay
okay okay so some of the I see so and
and so then that also meant that when
you're facing prosecution by the law
enforcement entities in the Judiciary
you're still feeling like you're
embattled and that that you have a moral
obligation in some sense to continue to
fight despite the costs when you when
you look at the situation now because
you're you're a changed man and we'll
get into that
you you talked about viewing law
enforcement as an enemy and an enemy
worth continually battling against even
at personal cost and not blaming your
father and you said you loved your
father and that he was a good father to
you when you look back on it now I mean
obviously your father and correct me at
any point if I've got this wrong but
obviously your father was engaged in
widespread criminal activity
how have you how why was that not an
issue when you were young why do you
think that his guilt on that front was
more or less invisible to you and and
how do you view his participation in
these activities and his hand in
establishing his Destiny even if he was
framed on those charges how do you view
that now
well totally different you know one of
the you know I've had many defining
moments in my life but when I stepped
away from that life and walked away I
had a lot of trouble Jordan I mean there
was a a contract on my life because you
can't walk away from that life and
everybody thought the the next step for
me would be to be a cooperating witness
because that's what happens normally
people don't just walk away
so I I was in prison at the time and you
know we can get into that how that
happened but
um the law enforcement the FBI came into
the prison and said
um there's a contract on your life
you're a dead man anyway cooperate with
us and they said and your father went
along with the contract
we got word from our informants
now I understood that you know I
understood that because sometimes in
that life if you uh propose somebody and
that person becomes an informant well
you could be held responsible in my case
probably not with my dad because of his
reputation there but it was possible so
I understood what he was doing it hurt a
little bit but it didn't bother me that
much because I I understood the life
well and I said well these are some of
the consequences I'm going to face I
don't believe my father would ever put a
gun to my head but he might have kept
quiet you know and just well hey my son
violated the rules
uh but it was really later on that I had
a conversation with him and this was
many years later after I walked away it
was probably maybe 10 or 12 years ago
and I said to him
I visited him in prison on his last
violation and I said you know Dad
our families destroyed I mean my mother
33 years without a husband at the end of
her life she died in 2012 for her
relationship with my dad can only be
described as ugly because she blamed him
for everything that went wrong what went
wrong I had a sister 27 years old died
of an overdose of drugs my brother 25
years a drug addict I can't even begin
to tell you what he put the family
through and me personally trying to keep
him alive on the street another younger
sister you know 41 years old she she
died of cancer but she was never
mentally stable
and I said you know dad you got to claim
responsibility for what you destroyed
our family because you was asking me you
know you walked away why did you do this
and I said because I didn't want to put
my family through what we went through
and you know he looked at me and he said
well none of this was my fault I said
what do you mean by that he's well I was
framed on this case
and I said dad you weren't framed
because you were a doctor a lawyer or a
priest you're afraid because of who we
were
I said you got to come to terms with
that because eventually you were going
to go down he wouldn't accept
responsibility so that's it so that's
interesting so okay so so so
let's let's talk about that a little bit
because that's extremely interesting so
because you might think that given that
he had lived
um an exceptional criminal life that he
would have been willing in some sense to
accept the guilt that would be part
parcel of that I mean if you engage in
criminal activities then you're doing
criminal things and obviously that's
wrong in some sense or it wouldn't be
called criminal and you'd think that
that would be part of the price you'd
pay for whatever success and respect you
might generate as a consequence of doing
that maybe whatever Adventure you might
have as a consequence of doing that but
the fact that he dwelt on the narrow
fact of his innocence in that regard
means to me in some sense that he was
denying his and I think this is what
you're telling me
is that he was denying his culpability
you know when you often hear that
um especially the high-level criminal
types are
um without conscience but that doesn't
seem to be an appropriate description of
the situation with your father because
if he was without conscience he would
have just said well of course I was
guilty and they framed me the sons of
[ __ ] but that's exactly what you'd
expect but you know I had it coming to
me in some sense because of all the
other things I did but you said that he
was clinging to his innocence and also
unwilling to take responsibility for
what he had done and and is that do you
think that's an exaggerated version of
what you had to do when you stepped
outside yourself so to speak to commit
the sorts of Acts that you didn't regard
as part parcel of you
yeah I think it could be described that
way yes you know and and I got upset
with him during that meeting too because
I said you know how could you not claim
responsibility for any of this
I said our family was destroyed and he
he refused to do it
um he was very now again I don't know if
he just couldn't face me and say it
maybe inwardly I can't look into his
heart and his mind but he was very
adamant about you know denying it and
maybe in some sense
um
I don't know maybe that had a carryover
effect on me during my time in that life
because my dad did teach me one thing
he said to me well it taught me a lot of
things that I thought were very helpful
to me but one of the things he said is
never admit to anything never no matter
what you don't ever admit to anything
let them prove it let somebody else
prove it and I saw that as being wrong
later on but during my time in that life
and growing up uh that's how I I would
never admit to anything if you guys want
to get me you got to get me uh you know
I'm not going to help you so that was my
mentality back then right right and do
you do you think that did carry did that
also carry over do you think it's hard
to practice something without it
becoming habit let's say and so you
might say well did that carry over to
your attitude to yourself because I am
very interested in that idea that you
brought forward earlier about having to
step outside yourself when you saw
yourself doing things that you didn't
regard as essentially you you know it's
a strange distinction right because
there's the real you that's doing the
things that are good and then there's
the sporadic you that are doing terrible
things but that's not really you there's
a a line of denial there and that's not
conscienceless in any sense it's just in
some sense it's the denial of conscience
and you did say that you know your
father seemed to
manifest the same
manifest the same attitude on a very
large scale
when you decided to get out of the
that that criminal life
was that a consequence of willingness to
preserve your family from the
catastrophes that you're that your birth
family had been through or was that
to what degree was that also
your willingness to look at those things
that you've done and to start seeing
them as part of you instead of part of
whatever it is that you were being when
you weren't being you
well you know there were there were a
couple of things that led to that
um you know Jordan one of the horrors of
that life
is that you make a mistake
your best friend walks you into a room
and you don't walk out again
and there was a night when I had that
experience you know there was a lot of
talk about me on the street I had a a
very big crew at that time we were
making a lot of money there was a
publication I think it was Newsday that
uh wrote a story that said I was getting
powerful enough to break away from the
Colombo family and start my own family
there was no truth to it it was
fictional story be now the media is and
so guys on the streets start to get a
little bit nervous of that especially my
boss at the time so without going into
all the details unless you wanted me to
they I always walked into a room one
night and I didn't think I was going to
walk out again and it was one of the
scariest times of my life it was not
heroic that I walked in it was more
robotic I just said hey if this is it I
was such a product mentally well I'd
like I'd I'd like to hear the details
tell tell me what happened so so you
were you were becoming very successful
and you were you were a story was
generated about you and the Press about
your Ambitions and obviously that caused
some concern so yeah tell me the details
okay well my dad was on Parole at the
time and I was a captain in a family
they had elevated me to that position
that's a powerful position captain
and my dad was also a captain and uh I
went to see him he said for me I went to
see him and we were in the driveway of
his house in Long Island and he said to
me the boss wants to see us tonight and
because my dad was on Parole and I had
no record at the time I drove him
everywhere I tried to Shield him from
people because he kept getting violated
so
um wherever he would travel he would go
with me I'd keep people away from him so
I said okay what time do you want me to
pick you up because we knew it had to be
a covert meeting because the boss was
also on parole and we couldn't all get
together because it would have been a
violation for the two of them
so he said well they want to do this
differently they want me to come in
first and they want you to come in
second
and I said well why do they want to do
that I said no we're not going to do
that you know the talk on the street I
said we're not going to do that why
would they separate us I said we'll go
together long story showed it was the
first time I really had an argument with
my dad ever in my life because always
respected him even if I disagreed with
him I did it nicely
but uh he was very adamant very
insistent he said we had an order we got
to do it that way I said okay
so another captain in the family called
me
um and he said meet me in Brooklyn on
18th Avenue and so I drove in from Long
Island
I met him I parked my car and I got into
his car now this is somebody I knew my
whole life he was in another Captain
equal rank with me when I got in the car
and the passenger seat there was
somebody sitting behind me
who I recognized but I didn't know well
and I started to get a little like
what's going on here
and it was about a 15-minute ride to the
house where we were meeting the boss at
that time and we had to do with covert
to make sure nobody was following us it
was a summer day in August
and when we parked the car we get out of
the car and it was about a 30-yard walk
from the car down to the basement
apartment where we had to go
and I get out of the car and I start to
walk and I the Fella's name was Jimmy
Jimmy I assume got behind me and the
other fella got out behind him and this
was a very bad setup Jordan I said
something is dramatically wrong here I
said this is wrong you know when I think
of this I'm telling you every time I
think of it it was that intense for me I
can hear like the crickets chirping and
I I see these little uh lightning bugs
that we had at the time in New York
and as I'm walking down there I'm saying
this is bad I may not walk out of this
room and I started to get very nervous
scared started praying I wasn't a
grateful guy at that time but I started
praying
and um I knew the setup you know walking
down those steps that door opens and uh
might be the last thing I ever see
um I don't know how I didn't faint when
the door opened but anyway
we go in I sit with the boss my father
wasn't there
and we go back and forth back and forth
and they were grilling me over money and
all this stuff and and what happened I
started to get mad I was getting angry
and I realize you don't ever get angry
with the boss that's a bad move and I
said look it looks like I'm walking out
of here let me just keep my cool which I
did and when it was over you know hey
let's have a glass of wine and
everything is good and we're hugging and
you know I I just wanted to leave so I
told Jimmy the fellow Drive I said Jimmy
drive me back to my car I got to go to
Long Island it's a long drive should we
get in the car
and I was really just about to I was
very angry with him because this is
somebody I knew all my life and I want
to tell him why didn't you prepare me
for this she was serious
and he looked at me and he said before
you go any further Michael he said I
want to tell you this he said this was
very serious tonight you held yourself
well in there could have been a problem
when he said that to me I got even more
upset with him I said you're my friend
you don't let me know you don't prepare
me give me a hint and uh he said no and
um
I'm sitting there and he said something
to me that really got to me he said if
it was the other way around would you
have told me
and I thought about it for a minute and
I honestly said no I wouldn't have he
said well
you know this life is well or better
than anybody you grew up in it he said
this is the life we lead
and I I was in silence uh for about 10
minutes I was just thinking about all of
this and then when I went to get out of
the car he grabbed my arm and he said to
me I want to tell you something you're
not going to you're not gonna like this
but you can take this to the bank he
said it just like that he said your
father was in there earlier tonight he
didn't help you one bit he hurt you in
there tonight
and I was I was pretty stunned I mean to
the point where I couldn't even ask him
what do you mean
but as I was walking back to my card
you're knowing my father so well I knew
what he did
he uh
he didn't help me he said look if my son
is stealing money or anything is going
wrong I have no idea he handles
everything you know I'm on parole I
don't get involved in anything he threw
me under the bus and I found out later
on that's exactly what happened so
it made a real impression upon me I said
man if this life can separate father and
son
you know after the bond that we had you
know both the Blood Oath that we took
and father and son I said what do we
really have here and um it was two years
later that I met my current wife which
was really my motivation for walking
away but I still say to myself I wonder
and I'm I'm not sure I'm saying if that
incident never happened would I ever
walked away because my dad had a very
strong hold on me as did the life
so all right I don't know I mean I I
don't know if I would have ever walked
away
well it's it sounds to me given
everything you've told me so far is that
the people who were involved in that
life
um set up a morality of it's something
like a morality of of patriarchal
loyalty
that goes above all else is that there
are like military that military will be
military style obedience is required
and that all morality is therefore now a
consequence of abiding by the rules of
the game and that would mean you
sacrifice your personal happiness you
sacrifice the stability of your family
you might even sacrifice the
relationship you have with your son but
the manner in which your moral is to
abide by the code of the family and that
sounds like what's inculcated
does that seem accurate absolutely
absolutely okay so so so that would also
mean that when you're when you were
viewing yourself doing things that you
didn't think were say integrally part of
the real you one of the other
justifications for that is well that's
the code that I'm bound to abide by
because I've decided to enter this life
and I've put my word on doing so and so
at the moment in order to continue that
and to abide by my word I don't really
have any choice that's accurate yeah one
of the things that really Disturbed me
about my dad is that
um he wouldn't take any responsibility
for it you know none at all and what I
what I had said to him on a few of his
violations I said Dad the family is
falling apart you need to leave New York
because you can't make it in New York
you need to get away from everybody and
preserve the family and he wouldn't do
it because his legacy in that life meant
more to him than anything else he wanted
to be known as the guy that would die
with his boots on he would never be an
informant no matter what he stood up you
know with a 50-year prison sentence
that's what he wanted to take to his
grave and that's what he did but in the
meantime the whole family was destroyed
yeah well I I think that I I I think
that part of the reason that the mafia
life
has such a grip on the popular
imagination is because of that weird
paradoxical relationship between the
strict moral code which is admirable
right like being able to abide by a
moral code is disciplined and admirable
and then that juxtaposed with the
criminality and the chaos that goes
along with that and the family price I
mean if you're just a run-of-the-mill
idiot
Street shoplifting Thug and you know
spinning off your idiot criminal uh
Enterprises which are likely to end in
catastrophe in a chaotic manner there's
nothing that interesting about your life
it's just kind of pathetic but the thing
that
and it usually has a pretty pathetic
outcome and generally isn't very
productive but the thing about the
organization that you're describing is
that there really is a an iron shod
ethos that goes along with it now but
what's interesting about it you know so
imagine that we look at your situation
we think
you had decided to abide by an ethical
order and that was the order of the
kazanostra families and you're bound by
that and then you might say well that
defines you but it doesn't exactly
because you said by your own testimony
that despite the fact that you had
identified with that ethic when you saw
yourself doing certain things you didn't
feel that was the real you and so then
the question would be well who is the
real you that that Mafia ethic is is is
transgressing against you know if if
it's something you did by choice which
which was the case and it was something
that you were disciplined to do you
might think well that's you but that
isn't the case what what you felt from
what you've told me is that you felt you
were violating the real you when you
were doing terrible things to abide by
these this ethos and so what do you
think now you're much older and you've
gone through many Transformations what
do you think the real you that was being
violated was and why wasn't that the
cause of Nostra you
well you know the fact that I was so
uncomfortable at times doing the things
that I was told to do
I liked it I I don't want to not accept
responsibility for what I did because I
think that's wrong especially at this
stage of my life
but I can't say that that's something
let's put it this way had my father
never introduced me to that life
I would have never gone down to criminal
path that's not who I was
um you know I wanted to be a doctor or
go on with my life in that way
but on the other hand I had it in me to
do what I had to do so I wonder myself
sometimes you know what is the real you
in other words if you were presented
with a situation when you had to do
something you did it is that the real
you even though you were uncomfortable
I've asked myself this question quite a
bit
um and I don't know you know like now I
wouldn't think of it I don't want to you
know hurt my family in any way I don't
want to do the wrong thing
but being I was capable of doing it back
then was it the real me is it the real
me well well that that that that is that
is the question in some sense and I
suppose that's also the question that is
relevant with regards to a conversion is
what is the real you
and I don't mean just you specifically I
mean the real human being
you might think that because you as I
said because you had decided to abide by
this moral code and that it was a moral
code that you wouldn't be conscience
ridden for doing some of the things you
had to do to stay part of the family
because you'd already defined yourself
in that way and also Define that as
ethical but it was still grating against
something in you and I would say
hopefully that whatever was calling you
to conscience was more the real you than
the you that was stepping outside of
your conscience to do the terrible
things that you did you know I do
believe that people have an intrinsic
sense of
well I think it's an intrinsic religious
sense in some sense and that's why
they're called upon by their conscience
period
now exactly what that means in the final
analysis I don't know but it's very
interesting to me that despite your oath
and your discipline following of the
appropriate practices that you were
still guilty and it's also interesting
to me that your father had to insist on
his innocence
and that that was what he used to escape
responsibility because he wouldn't
necessarily think that that was that
would be vital under those circumstances
but it was it was how he apparently it
was how he lived with himself
and and you said there was a kind of
there was a kind of I I hesitate to use
this word but there was also kind of
narcissism of Legacy associated with
that that's that's prideful I suppose he
said that he wanted to be viewed and you
can understand this and it is tough in
some sense that he wanted to be the
viewed as the guy who was so loyal that
he wouldn't crack no matter what
and even though that's misguided it's
not nothing right it's not just complete
chaotic
rule by whim there is an ethos there but
you know you said your your birth family
was completely destroyed by that ethos
it turned out that that doesn't work
very well
in the medium to long run and that would
be despite the money and the respect and
the power and all of that that went
along with it why do you think it was so
destructive for your family
I mean it was partly because your father
was jailed but that wouldn't be all of
it well a lot because
my mother you know which was very
difficult woman she
she didn't how could I put it she was
difficult with all the kids in the
family she couldn't handle motherhood
alone we needed a balance in the
household and uh he wasn't there to do
that when he was there there was a
balance even you know my brothers and
sisters were younger than me I kind of
became the father figure in the house
when he went away
um but my mother was such a strong
personality and there was nothing to
balance her out and then I think all the
kids had that same resentment for law
enforcement all of them and so it just
it just worked against them and then
dealing with my mother it was it was so
difficult like my brother you know I'll
tell you what happened to another
Dynamic
um my brother got himself in trouble
because he was constantly in and out of
trouble with drugs uh low-level stuff I
mean he was a drug addict and he would
do with drug addicts do and he got
himself in trouble and he wore a wire
against my dad and other people for over
a year
the last violation that my dad got and
the last case that he got my brother
brought it and actually testified
against him in court he went into the
witness protection program we didn't see
him I didn't see my brother for 10 years
when my dad was on trial and I went to
see the trial I was shocked seeing my
brother on the witness stand
but um since then my brother's cleaned
up his act and that he's no longer a
drug addict he's been clean for a while
and I sat down with him and I some of
the things that he was telling me about
his feelings inside and I believe he's
being honest with me I guess I never
realized how tortured my brothers and
sisters were over my dad being away my
mother being the way she was me you know
being not out of their life but you know
I got married and wanted to do my own
thing
um he just couldn't handle it he
couldn't handle it he had a big
resentment to my father big resentment
and that's what he didn't think he did
anything wrong I should you know John
his name was John I said you know Dad
almost died in prison as a result of
Your Action still your father he didn't
view it as anything wrong he said I had
to do this well you guys were you guys
were definitely in a bind with respect
to your father I mean so one of the
questions that popped up for me is you
you you still speak of your father as
far as I can tell with both love and
respect and so one of the re one of the
things I'm curious about is you know you
you told me that his actions destroyed
your family you told me that he was
involved in high-level criminal activity
that there's no doubt about that and
although he was framed on the charges
that he went to prison with and that he
Bears a tremendous amount of moral
responsibility for the Havoc that was
wreaked in his wake but it's clear to me
that you still love him and you respect
him and so I'm curious about why you
loved him and respected him first and
then well let's let's proceed from there
so what was it about the way that you're
farther interacted with you when you
were a kid and a teenager let's say and
maybe even later that produced this love
and respect despite the other elements
of his character
well he was always very supportive of me
when I was younger he really did want me
to be a doctor
um I think I was the only one in the
family that ever paid attention to him
in a way that he wanted me to wanted all
of his kids to because he was married
once before he had three children from
another marriage so there was seven of
us all together kind of a blended family
and uh I was really the only one that
paid attention to him and so and I did
everything to try to please him when I
was younger for some reason I just I
wanted to please him and I I tell you
this Jordan maybe this had a lot to
obviously it did
um I gotta go back my dad met my mom
when she was 15 years old
and
um he was married at the time
and the way the story goes and this is
probably going to blow your mind a
little bit my mother got pregnant at 15.
and I was born when she was 16.
and my father at that time being that he
was married in that life you weren't
allowed to get a divorce you weren't
allowed it was against the kosan oyster
rules
so my grandparents my mother's parents
were so upset because back then you
didn't have a child out of wedlock they
forced my mother to marry someone else
to say that that was her I was her his
child
and so I grew up for a short time
believing that my father Sonny was my
stepfather
I believe that he adopted me at an early
age because then his uh he left his wife
and then my mother and him got married I
think I was I don't know four or five
years old but his first wife left ran
away on his kids and so we had a a
blended family my mother was like 20
years old when his kids came into the
house and she didn't react well to that
and there was a lot of dissension in the
household and I grew up believing that
my mother was kind of mean to his kids
and that my father would turn on me
because I wasn't his real son
but he never did never did he always
treated me as well or better than
anybody else and I used to get mad at my
mother I used to say mom why are you
doing this she's going to turn on me one
day and she would always say no he won't
he won't don't worry about it but I
didn't understand why it wasn't two
years later years later when I found out
that he was my real father
and
um
you know so maybe it was me always
trying to please him and him always
treating me right that I had this real
love and respect for him that never went
away yeah yeah
yeah well that's very complicated you
know I read this book by Frank McCourt
called Angela's Ashes and Angela's Ashes
is a tremendous book and Frank McCord is
a brilliant writer and his father was an
absolutely destructive alcoholic in they
they grew up in Ireland many many kids
they grew up in poverty that was
unbelievably extreme they they lived in
a tenement house at one point that had
three inches of water in it in the
spring and and he had siblings who died
of I think
think it was tuberculosis doesn't matter
it was a an illness induced by poverty
and privation they often didn't have
enough food his father was always off
drinking up every scent the family had
on these alcoholic Benders that went on
forever and that was their life and you
know Frank was a very wise
child and he in some ways
compartmentalized his father into two
different persons there was sober
morning Father who was a pretty decent
guy and who actually loved him and who
spoke words of encouragement and then
there was drunk and useless nighttime
father and he more or less ignored him
and what Frank did was concentrate on
the positive aspect of the relationship
with his father and it's an amazing book
because it's written almost entirely
without resentment as far as I could
tell and you could also tell by reading
the book that Frank benefited from the
positive attention of his father to the
degree that he was able to Garner that
even though overall what his father did
was just murderously destructive in in
the most irresponsible possible manner
but you know you you said
that your father so you could imagine
that the best of your father came out
around you
and the best of your father was serving
the best in you he said he really did
encourage you and that does produce an
intense Bond you know because I don't
think that there is anything more
important that a father can do
for a child particularly a son although
not uniquely a son than to encourage the
best in them that's in some sense that's
almost the definition of paternal love
so then that would put you in a terrible
bind because you have the father who's
benevolent aspect is actually genuine
and genuinely focused on you and you
have a real relationship
and then you have outside of that father
the criminal father who's doing all
these other things that are in some ways
completely contradictory to that and
you know and your response was intense
loyalty to your father
yes
yeah and and I guess because he never
turned on me in any way
um I just always appreciated that so no
matter what he did later on it never
interfered with my love for him I might
have gotten upset with him
but I I couldn't not love him in any way
so
you know the other thing too Joe when I
when I left that life
um it was extremely difficult because I
felt that I was betraying my oath so I
would go to bed at night leaving the
life wake up staying back in I mean it
it took me years before I finally got
over it
um and I'm over it now obviously but it
took me a long time it was a real
struggle and challenge that's how much
of a hold that life had on me and I
think
not only because of the oath that I took
but really because of my father I didn't
want to let him down in any way it was
really a struggle
so let's turn to that you said that one
of the turning points was that evening
that you described earlier where you
weren't sure if you were going to walk
out alive and the fact that your father
in some sense threw you under the bus
um before that meeting and then also
your realization that had you been in
the same position as perhaps your father
and certainly your friend Jimmy that you
might have done the same thing that
obviously perturbed you to a great
degree but then you also said that you
met the woman that you are now married
to not long after that and that that was
also a turning point and so
how how did you meet her and and uh what
were you engaged in at that time and and
how how and why did meeting her change
you
well I met her on a movie set I was
producing a movie I had a uh film
Distribution Company production company
at the time that I was involved in
independent
and um we were filming a movie in South
Florida and she was one of the dancers
who was a dance movie I met her on the
set and she was 20 years old
and again very long story short I fell
in love with her really fell in love
with her obviously 37 years later and
um I just said you know she was a
Christian and her mom was a very devout
Christian
and I said at the time you know when I
was falling in love with her I said my
life is a direct contradiction to what
these women believe and they didn't
really know anything about me they were
from Anaheim California and I'm from New
York so I didn't really know anything
about me
but um when I fell in love with her and
I knew there was something happening
there I said am I going to marry this
girl and then put it through the same
thing my family went through because
Jordan I became such a Target they were
going to indict they were going to take
me down at some point in time you only
have a winning streak for so long
and I said I got to make a choice it's
either her or that life
and I chose her and that's when I
started to try to engineer this way for
me getting out of the life and part of
that was uh pleading to a racketeering
case the underlying Act was tax fraud
and accepting a 10-year prison term and
a you know a 15 million dollar
restitution with the forfeitures and all
of that marrying her moving out to
California and trying to you know
preserve my life and again with the
10-year sentence I was under the Old Law
at that time so I knew I could make
parole at some point which I did after
five years
um but that was the whole plan she kind
of became more important to me she
overtook even the love I had for my dad
did you get married before you went to
prison yeah we got married in in July of
85 and I went to prison in December of
85. okay so what was it about let's talk
about love for a minute there because
you also said that your love for her
transcended your your love both for the
life that you had embarked on and also
transcended the love that you had for
your father in some real sense and so
what do you make of that love I mean how
old were you when you fell in love with
her I was uh just about 32 years old
okay okay and so what was it about the
relationship you had with her and about
her that had that transforming how do
you account for that transforming
experience well a step back a little bit
I had been married once before
um I married young I married at 24. and
the girl I married who I cared for but I
don't believe I was ever in love with
her I loved her she was a good person uh
she stood by my side when we were going
through all of these troubles very close
with my mother
and that kind of you know almost I had
to get married in a way uh and but I
wasn't in love with her and so that that
marriage was kind of falling apart
mutually and then I meet her and we had
been separated my first wife and then I
meet her and I just knew that she was it
that was it it was the love of my life
for some reason it hit me in that way
and um
I don't know I just said you know I want
to be with this woman and you know let
me let me also be fair in saying this
I had become such a Target I had just
was acquitted in a huge case Rudy
Giuliani indicted me on a big
racketeering case I was a lead defendant
I had 15 co-defendants and at the day of
my arraignment I was she gave me a
million dollar bill at the time he told
me in the courtroom he said if I convict
you on this case you're going to get
double what your father got I'm going to
give you a hundred years Michael because
again I had a 14 agency task force that
was assigned to bring me down because I
had beat them so many times
and um after a several month trial I was
acquitted in that case some of my
co-defendants were convicted they got 30
years so I said he would have given me
at least 50. I said
there's no way that I'm gonna you know
beat this forever so I started seeing a
lot of things going wrong with the life
the racketeering laws were becoming very
successful a lot a lot of guys are
becoming informants and I think there
was two parts to it I fell in love with
her and she was the Catalyst that said
okay Now's the Time to make a move I
don't know if I would have made it if I
wasn't with her she was definitely the
motivation
but uh so it was all these things kind
of happening at one time in my head and
bingo I meet her at that time
and um
I said this has got to be my exit
strategy I got to get out of life I want
to be with this woman I don't want to go
into the witness protection program I
don't want to cooperate I don't want to
hurt anybody and that was a real dance
that was very very difficult okay so let
me ask you
a few thoughts on this so you talked
about the two different elements of you
um emerging when you were called upon to
to do things that you didn't think were
were Central to your nature let's say
and so and then there's the part of you
that did do those things which of those
two parts fell in love with her
foreign
hopefully that the better part yeah yeah
well that's what well this is this is
what I'm curious about you know because
obviously she was attracted to you as
well which is a mystery in some sense
right because you would think that given
your description of her and her straight
life and her Christian Origins that you
would be a dicey bat to say the least
and so what do you think she saw in you
that made her fall in love with you was
she looking at the was she looking
accurately at the positive part of your
character do you think
I do because I've been a good husband
with her I mean she's
you know she's the most important person
in my life I always put her on a
pedestal in many ways and and always
treated her well uh very appreciative
she waited for me all that time because
I I ended up doing eight years in prison
and she waited for me all that time
um you know so
I like to think that that's the real
part of me that she fell in love with
um
but you know the fact that you know
you're capable of doing other things I I
you know was conflicted with myself as
well who is the real you I mean yeah you
were uncomfortable doing these things
but you did them anyway so
you know that's still part of who you
are anyway
you know so I don't know it's it's hard
to say but
one thing that really motivated her too
her mother was a very very devout
Christian wonderful woman she's passed
on now but she took a real liking to me
and uh she prayed for me every day every
single day and she was very supportive
of me when I went into prison she held
her daughter up
she really did as well as the church
that we were involved in and she said
this is the choice that you made with
this fellow you're going to wait for him
because that's the right thing to do and
so her family became very supportive of
me also and all of those elements
combined I think were very helpful in in
maintaining the marriage because very
difficult I had a difficult prison time
because the government was very upset
with me they were trying to get me to
cooperate they shipped me to different
prisons around the country I actually
spent 29 months and seven days in
solitary
it was a six by eight cell 24 7 and uh
that's very destructive Jordan I I don't
agree with that especially for young
people it's very hard to get through
that and I saw a lot of guys that it
destroyed them totally destroyed them
but she waited on all of them how did
you how did you get okay so so we have
two Mysteries there now on the table one
is why this family decided to support
you obviously that did provide you with
a bridge out of your previous life so
that's one mystery why what in the world
did they see in you and why were they
willing to stake their like eight years
of their daughter's life on that and
then the second mystery is how in the
world did you survive with your sanity
intact through that period of of um
solitary confinement so let's start with
the first one her mother really liked
you now why in the world was that do you
suppose because you'd think in some
sense that her attitude would have been
oh my god get my daughter away from this
guy as fast as possible given you know
our Christian background and his and his
his behavior so what in the world did
what in the world went on there
well I think it goes to the type of
woman she was you know I had a
conversation with her one day and I told
her her name was Irma
and I said mama look I bring in some
baggage into this relationship because
of who I am and you know what I've done
in my life I said but I love your
daughter and I promise you I'll never
hurt her
and I said I love her very much and so
I'm going to do everything to help her
so when I go to prison
um I should I'll make sure that she's
comfortable
um one of the reasons why I took a plea
was so that I can maintain my wife's
lifestyle when I say lifestyle she
wouldn't have to go to work she wouldn't
have to do anything so as part of the
negotiation where I'd maintain the house
and money and all of that even though I
paid a big fine in restitution so I said
I'm gonna she's gonna be comfortable
while I'm away I should say I'll never
hurt her and from that moment on she
became my biggest supporter she believed
in me and because of her Christian faith
um you know she was very prayerful in
that and she said you know her daughter
this man loves you and if this is the
choice you're making then you have to
stick with it and her grandmother was
the same way and uh I think that was
Chris Camby was 21 years old when I
married her she was a good girl she was
a Christian but she was still a young
girl she was she was a dancer at the
time you know she uh
um
so I think that had a lot to do with it
and even when I was in prison I tried to
maintain one of the things that really
really scared me in prison
wasn't the prison experience but when my
dad went to prison back in his day he
was allowed one visit a month and one
three-minute phone call as a result of
that he wasn't
you know he just became so separated
from the family you know my brother had
cancer in his leg we never turned to my
father everything that went wrong in the
house we didn't turn to my dad because
he wasn't there we couldn't even discuss
it with him so he had no input and him
and my mother grew apart that's when the
kids started to grow apart from him I
maintained a relationship because I'd go
and visit him every month
and so I was afraid of that I said I
don't want that to happen with me and my
wife so fortunately the laws change
you're allowed to get on the phone when
I made my deal uh you know to take a
plea part of the negotiation where they
sent me to prison out in California so
I'd get visiting so I'd maintain that
relationship with my family all I cared
about in prison was maintaining a
relationship with her I was able to do
that so um
you know I took care of her in that
regard her mother just believed in me
and her father her father was kind of a
he had some he was an alcoholic he had
some petty little stuff on the street so
um he liked me a lot you know in that
regard I think maybe he looked at me wow
this is big time for him I don't know
but um
you know that's what held it together
and then you know she's a she's a
genuine person of Faith she's very
sincere in her faith that was her mother
so and then let's let's look at the
experience in prison so you were in
solitary you said for 29 months yes
okay so how in the world did you get
through that and what did it do to you
and was there any utility in it
or was it just torture
well emotionally and mentally it's
torturous you know when you look back on
being in solitary 29 days I can't
differentiate one day from another I
can't differentiate one hour from
another if I think back and you I I
don't know it was one long day one long
day that was it and
um for me at the time I dove into my
Bible this is when my my uh faith-based
transformation took place in solitary
dove into my Bible
I had my wife send me in several books
on all faiths and I started to study all
different faiths
and um it sustained me
in a big way I had a Sony Walkman I was
listening to a lot of the pastors that
were interpreting scripture I was trying
to make sense of it Jordan because you
know evidence has always played a major
role in my life because I was either
fighting my dad's case my cases it was
all about evidence for me so I'm I like
to see proof when I'm buying into
something
and for me uh there was enough proof it
was almost overwhelming to me that uh
scripture was real the Bible was God's
word and that Jesus was my savior and I
came out of there with that concept with
that belief and that's where the
transformation really started to take
place because I said you can't have one
foot in one foot out if you're going to
be a different person you've got to be
the right person and you got to maintain
that and even though you know I say this
you could take the boy out of Brooklyn
you can't always take Brooklyn out of
boy I still have things that I think
about my head and sometimes reactions
that I hold back for them thank God
but overwhelmingly my faith is worn out
and kind of keeps me on track that and
family obviously
so okay so you had you had three things
going for you then when you made your
transition to your new life you had the
love of your wife and her family
you had
faith and you had your your proclivity
for loyalty you said well when you went
into your new life you went all in
and so and then
you also talked about
the experience you had in solitary and
the evidence that you gathered you were
reading about different faiths what was
it about
why did you decide at that point to
start studying Faith traditions and more
particularly the Bible how was that a
consequence of the influence of your
wife or what do you think was happening
there
well it was uh to me it was divine
intervention because the first night I
was in the Hole uh when they violated my
parole
a couple of things happened I was
walking out of a bank in Brentwood
California and 15 agents captured me
threw me into Paddy Wagon and just took
everything I had at that point and they
were upset with me because I wouldn't
cooperate basically I was playing a game
with them making them think I was
because I was trying to just you know
get on the right side of the government
but not really giving them anything that
they can work with and finally they knew
that I was playing a game with them they
violated my parole and said they were
going to indict me on another case and
that I spend the rest of my life in
prison
and they drove me to the Lockup in in La
at that time they were going to
transport me back to Brooklyn in the
morning where the case was and that
first night in the hole okay so let me
give story I'm I'm confused here so tell
me when that was happening this was this
was before you struck the plea bargain
with the government this was after I had
done five years I was out on parole for
13 months a very difficult thing okay
and then the violation and
um that's okay okay yeah that first
night in the hole was honestly I was a
guy that was pretty much I can
accomplish anything that I want to
accomplish I was very determined uh I
had I had confidence not arrogance but
confidence in myself and
um this was the first night when I said
I think it's over for me I'm done
I said they took all my money because
they leaned all my bank accounts they
said they were indicting me on another
racketeering case and I know by fast
experience you don't be the case with a
public defender it cost me Millions to
defend myself and and become Victorious
at these trials
I said my wife she waited for me five
years
uh 13 very bad months on parole I had a
rough time you know people were after me
it was a very difficult uh game that I
was playing with them and I said how's
she going to wait for me now you know
I'm gonna lose the girl I did all of
this for we had two little babies
I said um and they're not going to put
me out on the yard I said I got people
looking to hurt me still because I
walked away I'm going to spend the rest
of my life in this hole and I really
felt for the first time in my life
hopelessness it's the strongest emotion
that I ever experienced that up to that
point
and um quite honestly Jordan if I could
have closed my eyes and not wake up
that's what I wanted it was too painful
to think about my future I said I was
only 40 years old or something I said
this is it I'm done
and a prison guard walked by my cell and
he looked in and he said you know you
don't look good tonight are you okay and
I I chased him away I should get away
from me to leave me alone I don't want
to see you guys and he came back about a
minute later and he pushed the Bible
through the slot in the door
and you know it was after a little bit
of time that I picked up the Bible and
that's when I started my journey
and it really started with the Book of
Proverbs The Book of Proverbs really got
me because of the wisdom and the
intelligence of Solomon I was wow you
know I never read the Bible you know I
grew up a Catholic but in Catholic
school you don't read the Bible you read
the catechism priest reads the Bible
from the pulpit on Sunday reads the
gospel so it was my first real
experience reading the Bible
and I just got hooked
and that's when the journey started and
I said look you know the way I reasoned
I said you know
I made two very bad decisions in my life
based upon loyalty I followed my father
blindly into this life I took an oath
and look where it got me I said I can't
do this the third time you know if my
what my wife and my mother-in-law are
telling me about eternity and Christ is
true I want to see it I want to believe
it I want to see the evidence and so my
journey was really in a search for
evidence that this was the truth not
justifying it and that's why I asked her
I said I want to read about Hinduism I
want to read about Judaism I want to
read about all religions send me books
and she did and I just came out of there
believing that was a long time ago
obviously it was in 19 I violated the
parole in 1991 and spent from 91 to 95
uh in there
but that's when my journey started and I
just came out of there very positive
that Christianity was the right way to
go
so in the first four or five years that
you spent in prison you were already
[Music]
um
affected in a positive manner by your
wife's love and and by your decision at
that point already to leave the life
that you had led yes but you got out on
parole and and things didn't work out
well and you said you said that had you
violated your parole when they picked
you up
well not you know I don't want to say
this but not really because I had failed
to file my income tax
and the reason I failed to file it
because they claimed that I had money
buried in certain places and my lawyer
advised me he said Mike if you don't
file it's a misdemeanor if you file
fraudulently and they ever find money of
yours anywhere he said that's a felony
they'll you know indict you again you're
going to spend another 10 years in
prison
so he said just don't file
so I didn't file when I was on Parole
however I had to report my earnings to
my parole officer every month so I
wasn't not you know I was still letting
the government know what I was earning
but I didn't formally file my income tax
and that was a violation
and they tried to I I honestly Jordan I
don't even remember some other silly
little things they put together but you
know when they want to violate your
parole they're violating you you don't
you know they don't need much at all so
uh but that was the basis of it
I see and so it was the second time that
you were put in prison that really that
really did you in the night that you
were that you were thrown in yes that
made you
like Rock Bottom hopeless yes rather be
dead than to continue the way that you
were and that's also when this prison
guard showed up with a Bible despite the
fact that you chased him away yes and so
what do you think you found so
compelling about it especially when you
were reading about other faiths at the
same time
you know the I think there was two
things I mean obviously you know so many
so many uh
you know stories in the Bible were
compelling to me but one of the things
that got me I became a new testament guy
because I really focused on you know the
the manhood of Jesus number one I wanted
to really look into Jesus character
since he's the basis about faith and
what kind of a guy he was because
remember this George my whole life from
the time I was a kid right through the
time I was in that life the standard we
had to live up to was to be a man's man
that's it you had Integrity you had to
be strong you had to be courageous and
tough and treat women the right way was
always that so I wanted to see I wanted
to study Jesus of Nazareth first to
establish if he was the kind of man that
I would follow
and he obviously came through with
flying colors for me with that and then
um one of the things that really got me
was that
after the apostles you know again it's
always this legalization that I put in
my mind after the apostles uh after
Jesus death the way the apostles stood
up and went to their death for someone
that had died
I really believed in the resurrection
and if there's no Resurrection there's
no really Christianity it's all about
the resurrection and their testimony
their witness meant so much to me it was
so powerful
and I said man I know guys in the life
that were turning informants left and
right and we were a life supposedly
built on loyalty and here's 12 men or
11.
um whose leader was dead and yet they
were willing to go to their death as a
result
that was very powerful evidence to me
and then things just kind of stemmed
from that because you don't die for
something you don't believe in you don't
die for something that is not real to
you at least I I can't I can't see that
you know even if it's if it's wrongly
real if it's real to you you may
sacrifice yourself for it but if it's
not you're not going to so that speaks
to that loyalty that speaks to that
loyalty that we were talking about
earlier that ethos of loyalty that you
had and so and then you also said that
the the rules that you had abided by
were the rules that you might say a
man's man would abide by but they were
insufficient in many ways given let's
say what happened to your family and
also your own experiences why did you
find the example that you encountered in
the gospels more compelling than that
you said because people were willing to
die for their testimony and that spoke
to the Loyalty but what was it about the
particulars of the Life of Christ that
also you found convincing and convincing
in a manner that would change the way
that you were interacting with the world
well you know I I started to think about
what where where the Loyalty really was
in our life and I
you know loyalty can be built it could
be built on love could be built on fear
and I started to think about it the
Loyalty in Mafia and closing or straight
to a great degree was built on fear
fearing of the consequences if you did
something wrong so you were loyal
and then I realized when all of these
racketeering laws started to come into
play
the fear of the mafia was transferred to
the fear of the government
because the government now would tell
somebody listen you're going to do 100
years if you don't cooperate with us and
all of a sudden you know the fear was
transmitted to that and so I said to
myself you know what real loyalty is
based upon love it's not fear
and because if you love somebody you'll
go to your death form I mean I know I
would for my kids my wife and
um yeah well you you also said that the
Loyalty that you had to your father was
basically based on love and not fear it
was it was it was based upon love I
didn't fear my dad in any way
and like I said I mean I would have I
would have walked into a room with him
even after they told me you know she
went along with the contract because I
don't believe he would have ever done
that and if he did well you know it
would have been my tough luck but it was
always love with my dad
but um and I just saw the way Jesus
expressed himself
to his followers
and you know no greater love than for
someone to give their life for the
people that they love and and um I just
saw that as very powerful now before
that without getting into all the detail
I had to First establish that scripture
was real
and what I'm reading is real it's not a
novel or a fairy tale or fake or any way
and um you know I put that together
methodically in my head at that time
that no this is real this is trustworthy
I can trust the Bible the evidence is
pretty clear
and so uh it's almost like I went to
trial I took the Bible on trial during
that time I had nothing but time on my
hands Jordan so
um you know I often wonder if I didn't
get in the hole during that time if I
ever would have strongly become a
Christian because I think I needed that
time totally to myself
uh with no distractions whatsoever other
than you know worrying about my family
on the outside uh in order to really
convince myself
uh through this search that it was real
you know in the past 25 years it's only
become more real to me
um you know not only in my life but in
the life that I've seen you know and
others that that God has done so
you know I tell people you know this is
not based upon some whim or some fairy
tale or hey it's it's you know it feels
good to go to church and and hear the
message and see the you know get
involved in the worship music for me
it's it's pretty real not saying that
I'm perfect in any way you know because
you still have sinful Tendencies no
doubt but you get better you have to be
better if you're not better then
something's wrong then it's not real
so how did you start to change during
the second prison term as a consequence
of this
unfolding decision
what did you stop doing and what did you
start doing and how did that change life
for you in prison
well again in the whole there's not much
you can do you're just there 24 7 but
um you know something happened during
that time Jordan this this hatred that I
had for law enforcement there was a case
going on in Chicago
and
they wanted me to testify in that case
as a matter of fact they said they were
going to indict me probably something
they couldn't have indicted me it was
somebody that I knew
and I'll tell you what happened they
came and picked me up in the middle of
the night
and they were one FBI agent came and was
bringing me to uh Chicago to talk with
the U.S attorney
and it was me and him
I was handcuffed we were on a flight and
we get to the airport in Chicago and I
hardly even spoke to this guy I didn't
want to talk to him
and we get to the airport
and he says to me wait here he took the
handcuffs off me he said I'm going to
get my car
I said what
I said I'm a federal inmate I said he's
leaving me in the airport all alone now
I'm wondering if this is a setup I'm
saying what what's going on here I'm
starting to get a little nervous you
know and he doesn't come back for about
20 minutes
and I'm in the airport by myself I'm
looking around I'm saying something's
going on here this guy first of all he
loses job if I ran away be in a lot of
trouble just left me there
and then he comes back and I get in the
car with him and I'm driving with him
and I told him his name was George I
said pull over he says well I should
pull over right now
and he said what's wrong I said no
what's wrong with you what what's going
on here as you leave me in the airport
you're a federal agent 23 years on the
job I hear I said you could have lost
your job if I ran away he said I'm
trying to establish some trust with you
he said I just put my self on the line
with you he says and I you got to be
able to trust me and I got to be able to
trust you
and that whatever I'm asking you you're
going to tell me the truth
something happened I had never witnessed
anything like that from a federal agent
or anybody in law enforce well local
cops different
but I established a friendship with this
guy
and I said I'm going to tell you the
truth it's not going to help your case
but I'm going to tell you the truth and
um he became a dear friend
he turned my whole head around about law
enforcement
because I used to look at them like
there were some aliens like they didn't
know how to tell the truth they were
corrupt they were just bad people
and that would that yeah that put me on
the road of changing my whole attitude
and accepting the fact that no we were
the bad guys
you know I mean there's bed and
everything you know but we were the bad
guys these are decent people and since
then I've met so many I have so many
friends in law enforcement now yeah well
it's a it's a rough thing when when when
you put the Locale of evil somewhere
that's convenient
you know it should be somewhere
inconvenient right it should be in the
middle of your heart but if you see it
in other people then as soon as you see
it as essentially in other people then
you're justified in taking whatever
stance you want against those other
people and then you have no
responsibility except to take that
stance and that's pretty convenient for
you right because it's not your moral
problem man it's them they're bad
they're the ones who are bad right
you know and now even on you know social
media I have a big platform also
you know people if I'll say something
about my dad they'll come out and say
well why do you defend your dad he was
your murderer and he was this and that
and that and I don't even get offended
by that anymore because I understand
that's that's the way people should
normally think because that's the life
that my dad was part of there's a life
that I was part of at one time would
have been terribly offensive to me but
now I get it I understand that's the
right way to think in many ways
so you know I think it was a whole this
had to be a whole change of mindset that
occurred in me over a period of time
just from meeting different people
studying my faith
um you know I met so many genuine people
I one of the Pastors in my church the
guy that married us she was Dr Myron
Taylor he's passed on now but um
when I was in prison in the hole he was
sending me books and then he sent me
money for commissary
and I told my wife one day I said why is
he doing this I don't know him well he
doesn't have to send me money I don't
feel right and she told me she said
listen he loves the Lord and turn he
loves you just don't worry about it buy
some soup and commissary so
um and he was such a genuine person
genuine wasn't looking for anything he
won anything he was just a real person
and he was true about his faith he
didn't hit me over the head with it or
anything like that but
I I just started to meet people that
started to turn my head around and break
this other mentality that I had
it took it took time
yeah well it's it's a 180 shift and it
and with shifts like that there's often
plenty of backsliding I mean you don't
develop a whole new you overnight it
takes a lot of discipline it takes as
much discipline to become good as it
took to become bad to begin with I would
think or perhaps more so what have you
done since this transformation that you
think has been good and do you think
that do you think do you believe do you
feel that you have in some reasonable
measure atoned for your past
well you know it's very interesting that
you say that I don't believe
that we can ever make up for our past
what's done is done and that's one of
the things that I that have really
attracted me to the Christian faith
how do you make up for some things that
you've done in your life they're already
done they're done you know
um especially in that life
but based upon Christianity if you're
sincerely sorry for your sins and accept
Christ well then your sins are forgiven
so do I believe my sins are forgiven
absolutely I 100 believe that because
that's a basis of our faith if I didn't
believe that there's there's nothing to
believe in
and what happened Jordan when I was
coming out of prison that last time they
finally let me out of the hole for a few
months that I had uh left to for my time
well the FBI came to me and they said we
need a favor from you we want you to
participate in a video that all the pro
leagues are getting involved in about
the dangers of gambling to their
athletes
very long story short I participated in
that video inside the prison and said
this is how we set up the athletes this
is exactly how we did it and this is
what they should watch and and be
careful of well when I got out the
leagues came to me directly and to make
a very long story short I started
speaking with all the to all the bowl
players back in 1996 when I got out of
prison about the dangers of gambling the
relationships that they keep that led to
me speaking in churches giving my
testimony and that's been going on since
1996 I've been all over the world and
all different forums I've spoken at over
1600 churches and Ministries throughout
my time so I think I think that was
God's plan and purpose for me and I
totally believed totally believe that
you know what the enemy meant for bad
God will turn around and use for good in
our life if we allow him to so I think
the platform that that I went into was
was huge because
people are so intrigued with the Mob
Life Everywhere You Go I mean I found
out you know in China the biggest movie
ever in China was The Godfather I've
experienced that in Singapore Australia
you name it I just did a 16 City Tour
and the United Kingdom and you would
have thought I was a rock star I
couldn't believe it yeah well I I think
it I think it does have something to do
with that
strict sort of hyper masculine ethos
that you know we live in pretty chaotic
times morally and any any example that
constitutes abiding by a strict code is
therefore extremely attractive at an
unconscious level I think one of the
things that's so interesting about your
story is that you abided by that ethos
you saw that that despite the fact that
it was strict and had a certain degree
of admirable loyalty let's say
associated with it and a willingness to
make sacrifice that all things
considered it was still extremely
destructive and counterproductive
especially at the familial level but
also socially more broadly and then you
found a path that you regarded as
equally admirable or
on in in in in in with regard to loyalty
and the willingness to make sacrifices
but also had additional components that
your previous lifestyle didn't have at
all
and so that's that's resulted in this
transformation
and so it's it's it's a it's a story
that's remarkable in two fronts is one
is well you were an Exemplar of this
first ethos that has this unconscious
attractiveness associated with it and
second you found that that wasn't good
enough and you needed something and
found something that served you and
everyone else better
so makes quite a compelling story and
it's a hard one to deny
especially when you've been that far out
on the criminal front and then flip and
then flipped around 180 degrees and also
how painful that was to actually manage
so yeah let me ask you this
um I have said this many times I don't
think that
anything everything that's illegal is
not necessarily immoral and I've said
this I've said it from you know the the
stage in church
I said I have no moral issue whatsoever
with stealing tax money from the
government I'm being honest I would not
lose a night's sleep in doing it
I won't do it because I'm accountable
now to God and to my to my family I
don't want to put them in trouble I
don't want to make mistakes like that
people rely on me for a lot of things
but morally I don't have a problem with
it and I'm being honest and I often
wonder myself I said well why don't you
have a problem with it it's it's illegal
you're not supposed to be doing it
you're supposed to abide by the law but
and like I said I won't do it
but I don't have a moral issue with it
so I don't know where that puts me at
times
is that still the old me or is that
justified because I believe the
government is corrupt I I mean I read
about it every day I just wrote a book
Mafia democracy about the government
yeah well maybe maybe you can't maybe
you can't fight corruption with corrupt
you know maybe that just doesn't
even even if you're even if your
fundamental point is accurate you know
and maybe that's part of the ethos of
turning the other cheek which is very
complicated thing to think through right
because it can look like weakness that's
for sure and I think often when people
do it it is weakness it's not out of
moral virtue but it can be
I know I think if you turn the other
cheek and you don't have to
well then maybe that's something that's
ethical and I do think it's very it's a
dicey thing to fight corruption with
corruption and maybe that was part of
the problem with you regarding the
police as enemies you know and and then
being willing to engage in criminal
Enterprise in some sense for for revenge
is that even though
to whatever degree your supposition was
correct the manner in which you chose to
fight wasn't wasn't productive it was
just going to make the problem worse
yeah that makes a lot of sense you know
another thing I have this issue with my
wife maybe you can help me there too
my father always taught me he said
Michael don't ever lie to hurt somebody
but if you have to lie to help somebody
that's okay
and I've lived by that code throughout
my life I'm not gonna lie to hurt
somebody but I'll definitely lie to
defend somebody and help somebody and my
wife said a lie is a lie it's wrong I
feel and I try to explain it I said wait
a second if I had to protect our son
from something that he did would you
want me to just give him up if he was
wrong or should I protect him I said my
instinct is to protect him I don't know
how to do it any other way I said I
couldn't do it
um and she you know she she has a
problem with that I think you can find
yourself in situations
where the best
alternative that confronts you is to lie
about something but then I would say in
all likelihood there was a whole series
of micro lies that put you in that
circumstance
and so you have to be hyper awake
to make truth always work for the good
you know there's a poet in Canada
Leonard Cohen and he said there's no
decent place to stand in a massacre and
the idea would be well by the time
you're in the massacre you've made so
many moral errors that all you have are
variant forms of hell around you
there's no there's lesser there's lesser
Hells and greater Hells but that's it
and I think very often when people are
called upon to lie in the service of
something positive they've already
compromised themselves so badly in 50
ways that that's the best alternative
that that that lays open to them you
know I think I think your wife is
fundamentally right
I also think though that sometimes it's
your best bet
you know there's there's a classic
example let's say if you were in Nazi
Germany and you had Jews hiding up in
your attic and the Nazis came to the
door and and they said
do you have any
unwarranted people living in your
household unauthorized people well if
you weren't gonna lie you'd say yes and
then those people would die
but then I would say well you know 10
years ago you should have said something
about the Nazis when they were first
starting to gain power and you didn't
and now you're in this hellish situation
where you have to lie for the good and
that means that you have already put
yourself in a place that's not tenable
and so that's how it looks to me
interesting that makes sense
yeah well it's it's it's it's a hard
thing to make sure that you're stepping
on firm ground with every word all the
time
that's that's a that's a very
rough challenge but I but I do think
that's what living in truth
fundamentally means um it's a call to
being awake
Non-Stop and
that may mean if you're not awake enough
you may find yourself in a position
where the best you have is a white lie
you know people have asked me these
sorts of things trivially like
um if your wife comes to you and she's
bought new outfit she says well how does
this look
um your best bet is to say well it looks
great dear and and I would say that's
not really your best bet because it's
better if she can rely on your word and
maybe you're the right answer in that
situation is
um don't ask me questions that you don't
want an answer to
right it's you know what I mean is that
there if if you if you if you step
carefully enough sometimes even in
awkward situations and I know that's a
relatively trivial example you can find
a way of telling the truth that serves
the good and doesn't betray someone
that's still true
you know you have to wrestle with
yourself to make that happen but but you
can make it happen almost always
understood
so yeah well look it was we're running
out of time on this front I want to talk
to you for another half an hour behind
the daily wire plus platform as most of
you who are watching and listening now
know I do an extra half an hour
interview with all my guests uh to walk
through some of the more details some
more of the details of their life and to
find out I suppose what success looks
like and so that's what we'll be delving
into
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com